[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24 sólo
el 12% de los países se protege a las
mujeres del impacto económico y social
del cobi 19 según un análisis que fue
realizado por 1 mujeres y por el
programa de las naciones unidas para el
desarrollo de 206 países y territorios
revisados apenas 25 adoptaron
disposiciones contra la violencia de
género de apoyo a los cuidados no
remunerados y de fortalecimiento de la
seguridad económica de las mujeres uno
de esos pocos casos ejemplares está en
américa latina'
argentina está entre los países que sí
ha tomado medidas
no es secreto que a nivel mundial se
incrementaron los casos de violencia de
género en pandemia en argentina también
la línea de asistencia a 144 recibió
durante este periodo un 48 por ciento
más de llamados que en el mismo periodo
del 2019 como una forma de darles cobijo
un club de la ciudad de buenos aires-
nueva chicago cuyo equipo de fútbol
juega en la segunda división ofreció
parte de sus instalaciones en las que
hasta septiembre había alojadas unas 10
mujeres con sus hijos nuestro
corresponsal no está lejos hoy nos
cuenta la historia
como todos los clubes de la ciudad por
la pandemia de kobe 19 nueva chicago
está sin actividad desde hace meses su
equipo de segunda división del fútbol
argentino no pisa el césped sus hinchas
no llenan las gradas pero no está vacío
esta cancha cubierta de basket se
convirtió en hogar para mujeres víctimas
de violencia de género y sus hijos que
es lo que llevó un club de fútbol como
nueva chicago a ofrecer sus
instalaciones para que pudieran venir a
resguardarse mujeres víctimas de
violencia de género teniendo en cuenta
el fuerte trabajo que está haciendo el
club en cuanto a lo que es violencia y
todos los cursos y talleres que hacen
todas las actividades y deportista de la
institución
inclusive profesores y número comisión
directiva la decisión fue cederlo al
espacio de la mujer que es el número 144
si cualquier mujer se puede comunicar y
en ese sentido cederlo para que sea
utilizado por ellas y en un contexto de
mayor demanda de asistencia por
violencia de género contar con este
lugar fue muy importante la pandemia si
en términos de violencia de género y
para las mujeres
agudizó todo tipo de situaciones esta
mujer que antes tenía su espacio que se
juntaba con otras mujeres que tenía sus
espacios de encuentro cuando los chicos
chicas estaban en el colegio hoy ya no
lo tienen y todo el tiempo está con el
agresor conviviendo en el mismo lugar
aunque por seguridad ninguna de las
mujeres alojadas aquí hablo frente a
cámaras y conversé con una de ellas sin
grabarla me dijo que cuando llegó al
club con sus hijos no terminaba de
entender porque era ella la que estaba
en situación de encierro se quería ir
pero ahora que llegaba el momento de
irse tras conseguir un nuevo lugar para
vivir
le costaba dejar este espacio con el que
se había encariñado y a sus padres cuyo
apoyo le resultó invalorable para el
club esta iniciativa es parte de un
proceso de un trabajo que busca romper
con el vínculo entre violencia y fútbol
tan arraigado en el ambiente de este
deporte en argentina que este espacio
sea un lugar de cobijo para víctimas de
violencia de género es un paso en esa
dirección
para conversar sobre el caso de
argentina e invitamos a lucia martelotte
ex coordinadora de programas de 1
mujeres en argentina y también nos
acompaña laurana malacalza subsecretaria
de abordaje integral de las violencias
por razones de género del ministerio de
la mujer de argentina bienvenidas a ella
soy
gracias comienzo con ustedes laurana
porque argentina es una historia
diferente en una larguísima lista de
países que fallan y además atrozmente en
la protección de la mujer y ojo porque
no digo que ya hayan cumplido la meta
pero si se acercan en esa dirección
si para creo que ha sido muy importante
los efectos que ha generado un
movimiento social tan trascendente en la
región como el movimiento feminista en
argentina y sin dudas la la decisión de
del gobierno nacional de crear un
ministerio de las mujeres género y
diversidad esa conjunción de fortalezas
entre las organizaciones de la sociedad
civil y el estado
ha permitido nos ha permitido de alguna
manera a jerarquizar las políticas en
materia de violencia de género la
creación del ministerio de las mujeres
género y diversidad de la nación ha sido
clave en este sentido y para nosotras
desde este ministerio poder impulsar
toda una serie de acciones en materia de
prevención de las violencias en materia
de asistencia de las personas en
situación de violencia de género y de la
protección de estas personas en un
contexto de pandemia en un contexto de
aislamiento social muy importante y sin
dudas digamos algunas definiciones en
materia de generar un mayor acercamiento
de los dispositivos estatales para las
personas que están en situación de
violencia de género ha sido clave lo
mismo la articulación con otros
ministerios para poder promover
instancias de asistencia para poder
continuar con los procesos de
investigación y de sanción en las
instancias judiciales y también ha sido
fundamental como bien lo marcaba la nota
recién la articulación con otros
espacios de la sociedad civil sin duda
las instituciones deportivas
los hoteles sindicales
han sido centrales para poder acompañar
al estado en materia de protección de
las personas en situación de violencia
de género durante la pandemia del gobi
lo bueno este informe es precisamente la
razón que nos reúne aquí y quisiera
hablar también de las grandes
conclusiones que presenta el documento y
por qué en general los países no hacen
de la protección de las mujeres una
prioridad se le pregunto a usted lúcida
martelotte y por qué está claro además
en otros informes que ustedes mismos han
presentado que cuando la mujer tiene
buenas condiciones de vida esto a la
larga va a redundar en el desarrollo de
las naciones
sí muy muchas gracias por la invitación
creo que el informe esté muy interesante
y da cuenta como vos comentabas que son
pocos los países solamente el 20% de los
países
adoptado medidas en las tres es un
informe que tiene en cuenta tres grandes
áreas una es la violencia contra las
mujeres otra tiene que pagar con las
tareas de cuidado no remuneradas y en
tercer lugar todo lo que se vincula con
la seguridad económica de las mujeres y
lo que muestra el estudio que son pocos
los países que han hecho esto de manera
integrada como es el caso de argentina
el resto de los países tienen medidas en
algunos de los ejes pero no en los tres
ejes y algo que se sigue viendo es que
todavía el foco sigue estando puesto
especialmente en la violencia contra las
mujeres que como decimos es un problema
de corte global estructural muy complejo
que afecta a una enorme cantidad de
mujeres pero no es el único problema que
tienen las mujeres y creo que es
fundamental que los países puedan pensar
en políticas que tengan trabajar con las
causas estructurales de las
desigualdades como son por ejemplo la
organización social de los cuidados y
como la argentina estuvo avanzando en
algunas medidas que tienen que ver con
la red redistribución de estas tareas
para que justamente podamos lograr la
igualdad de género sobre todo en la
pandemia que sabemos que se han
exacerbado las desigualdades en
diferentes ámbitos
bueno laura usted trabaja en el
ministerio de la mujer y esto es muy
destacable porque significa que
argentina ha dado un paso más para poner
a las mujeres como foco de las políticas
públicas y darles la protección y la
importancia pues que merecen veíamos el
ejemplo del club chicago en el reporte
que pasamos hace un momento
buenos aires- ahí realmente aplicó una
política real de responsabilidad social
las mujeres de que albergaron ya fueron
trasladadas a otros lugares con unas
condiciones más favorables para ellas
inclusive usted cree que esta acogida
que se les dio en este lugar o que este
tipo de espacios nos están hablando de
un despertar hacia otra cultura una
cultura que prefiere proteger en vez de
lastimar
sí por supuesto el compromiso de las
distintas organizaciones de la sociedad
civil son fundamentales para desarrollar
las políticas en materia de igualdad de
género y para desarrollarlas en materia
de violencia por motivos de género para
nosotras ha sido fundamental la creación
del ministerio para tener en cuenta las
instancias de desigualdad y de violencia
que sufren las mujeres pero también el
colectivo lgtb y no binaria para nuestro
ministerio es un ministerio que impulsa
incorporar no solamente digamos un
abordaje integral de las situaciones de
violencia sino dos perspectivas que son
centrales para pensar realidades que
componen nuestro país que es la
perspectiva de la intersección alidad y
la perspectiva de la diversidad para en
ese en ese sentido el compromiso con
todas las organizaciones sociales con
las organizaciones territoriales
feministas y de la sociedad civil ha
sido clave y es clave para el desarrollo
de estas políticas en materia de
igualdad y de lucha contra las
violencias por motivos de género
y pasó nuevamente a usted lucía para
hablar de las iniciativas que se
desarrollan en argentina y pues bueno
también sigamos hablando de feminismo
porque desde el principio del programa
ha sido muy marcado que argentina es
visto como un país líder en américa
latina en las causas feministas en las
causas por las mujeres las grandes
manifestaciones los vemos a partir en
ese lado del continente así que cuál
quiere usted que ha sido la diferencia
para que en argentina las mujeres hayan
levantado su voz con tanta fuerza y pues
sirvan de ejemplo para que otras mujeres
también
pidamos nuestros derechos
bueno creo que esto tiene que ver con la
historia de lucha y con la fortaleza que
tiene el movimiento de mujeres y
feministas argentinas es uno de los
pocos países de la región en los que se
generan encuentros nacionales de mujeres
desde hace más de 35 años esta es la
primera vez que por la pandemia no vamos
a poder reunirnos presencialmente pero
creo que la fortaleza que tiene el
movimiento de mujeres es parte de lo que
explica porque pudo crearse además la
voluntad política obviamente el
ministerio de las mujeres géneros de
diversidad que era uno de los grandes
reclamos que este gobierno atendió del
movimiento feminista y como también eso
se ha traducido en mujeres que están
comprometidas mujeres y personas lgtb y
que están comprometidas con la causa y
que están en posiciones de toma de
decisión y que sea
bien dijimos reflejado que argentina sea
uno de los países y ejemplares en la
cantidad de medidas que ha tomado que
tienen que ver no solamente con la
violencia contra las mujeres que las ha
tomado también pero medidas que están
vinculadas con la seguridad económica o
con los cuidados por ejemplo en el caso
de teletrabajo hay una disposición que
dice que las mujeres que tienen cargas
de cuidado pueden adaptar su ex horario
para que puedan conciliar su vida
laboral con la vida familiar o por
ejemplo también que se ha promovido la
inserción de mujeres en el programa
promover trabajo para que las mujeres
víctimas de violencia y en situaciones
de mayor vulnerabilidad puedan acceder a
autonomía económica que como sabemos es
fundamental para que puedan salir de
situaciones de violencia entonces creo
que lo importante es que en argentina se
ha adoptado un enfoque integral que
permite hacer frente a las diferentes
desigualdades que tenemos en materia de
géneros bueno pues se nos acabó el
tiempo pero muchas gracias a ambas por
estar con nosotros en ellas hoy por
estas explicaciones que nos dan y pues
es muy importante destacar cuando las
cosas van en la dirección correcta sin
embargo
y lastimosamente solamente conoceremos
los efectos reales que esta pandemia
ejerció sobre las mujeres en algunos
meses sigan con nosotros en france 24 y
nos vemos próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]